Barranco is one of Lima's trendy neighborhoods.
In the 80s, it was more of a Bohemian artist community...
...and now it's very popular for young people...
...for nightlife, for cafes, and it generally has a very cool vibe.
Its artistic roots show on the walls, inside the shops...
...and just in the general laid-back attitude...
...of these homey streets.
This neighborhood is really trendy right now,...
...but it still kind of feels like a walk back in time.
There was something nostalgically old-fashioned...
...about Barranco, which I think is what makes it so popular,...
...and its name translates to "cliff"...
...as the area is actually located right along the cliff's edge.